президент Прем'єр їздять по всьому світу
і збирають озброєння звертаються до
урядів до міністерств оборони різних
країн на всіх континентах з тим щоби
знайти знайти якесь озброєння В той
самий час чомусь не закладається мало
недостатньо закладається коштів для
закупівлі такої воєнної техніки чомусь
недостатньо закладається коштів для того
щоб закуповувати озброєння і
найголовніше це
періодично потребує ремонту і тому зараз
найважливіше Я вважаю треба додати
коштів і тому я пропоную тих 17 млнів
додати додаткових для того щоби
озброєння додаткове озброєннячи 17 млрд
для того озброєння мало можливість бути
зремонтоване це і робочі місця і це
безпека і життя наших військових
президент Прем'єр їздять по всьому світу
і збирають озброєння звертаються до